hello and welcome to this video yeah I
hope this will not be a super long game
I tried to just cool squeeze in some
games while cooking and I have something
in the on the game before already
featured my kitchen time a night a three
what the heck send me a check back
really really odd move it irritated me a
lot
how can you play night 83 and this is a
mouse lip I don't know yeah I know all
that much and it's not very exciting
well okay I mean one thing that you
definitely get from the from the Petri
office you get a fair amount of endings
endings simplified positions peeling it
really is a good school of end game play
so let's see what I can do here I mean
in them it is fairly symmetrical of
course but I maneuvered the night to e6
one reason is that I'm blocking the
e-file that way and I hope to prevent
yeah more trades okay um it's night age
five an idea trying to get the bishop he
can go Bishop age four though but just
get this Bishop well so nice little okay
I'll take it
it's a nice little step towards some
imbalances okay so the fire
maybe White's idea yeah it's actually if
I go d5 it is actually not that easy to
prevent 95 195 I can take before okay I
can take you fall right or is it is
there something dangerous on the cards I
don't see it I don't see it I think I
can take the poem yeah but I have a 5
right at least f5 I can also move the
King maybe to e6
I mean I'm sd-6 of course to d6 yeah
let's do it
maybe rook e1 no we place a passive move
okay the short of 6
and no create yeah it's a point it's
just a pawn bishop g5f Foreman yeah I
think rook e8 is a simple and good news
he would like to play rook e1 but that
would belong to c2
and I don't I don't really see how I can
put more pressure on that night so I can
double on the e-file eventually going
okay one maybe okay so if I go rookie
one and we trade rook trade one look
then c2 will be hanging now after rook
to see one yeah okay the other thing is
that night is unprotected so if I move
my knight I will attack his Knight
the question is do I have a good square
to go to I don't really see a good
square to go Joe I mean something really
convincing I don't see okay let's how
Roxy one is the most obvious move if he
goes nighty to however that's a bit of
an annoyance because Roxy to rook takes
d4 and the game continues I am better
but it's not the the easiest to win ever
[Music]
hmm yeah I'm not entirely certain
okay I'm playing a wedding move don't
didn't really see anything great
you know 91 maybe 1930s s idea I cam
putting this back maybe wants to play
see phone yeah not so happy with what I
did here definitely squandered some some
of my advantage
I certainly had a position that was
close to close to winning and now this
is some minutes upon but it's nothing
nothing great
yeah I wonder ever should trade trade
the night with my trade the rook with
night b5 I'm sorry I'm a little bit
uncertain about it know that I have to
do
yeah that's winning now completely the
bishop is absolutely killing killing the
knight
and if I've gets the new person okay so
let's have a look
he gave me default for nothing much and
yeah I mean here I'm quite happy that I
have the bishop there so I have
something to to to play for but after
normal moves it's important that ninety
five doesn't work otherwise he could
such a simplify even more let's say he
plays a move like this I will play
exactly f6 preventing this and now I can
try to slowly never slowly push forward
king f7 Bishop d6 b v a5 gain space
based on the bishop pair it's a bit term
it's a slight advantage it's not much
but it's a side advantage i felt he
should simply play Bishop h4 here after
which I have f6 but still I think this
is better than just letting me take it
on on g3 yeah but I did not play this
this right really Knight XE 2 is already
stronger huh that I should have done
this is already an improvement because
no it doesn't matter how it takes now I
get bishop against Knight and the good
thing is first of all the bishop is
better than the 19 of course but also I
prevent opposite colored leadership
missions here the bishops of opposite
colors are always drawing factor which
should be avoided yeah TM I kind of
squandered it away a little bit it okay
it's so it's still okay yeah for sure
but here took ages and I didn't find
anything super convincing okay one is
okay the main issue was I wanted to do
this originally but I thought 92 was an
annoyance yeah I thought this this might
win but I really felt it's not necessary
I can't take on f2 I didn't see that f2
is hanging that is the thing
basically I thought everything wins but
the dead wasn't all that is evil but it
was an enormous help that he played this
now you have to basically go here I mean
it's not nice but it's it's better than
this which is like a completely forced
sequence and then we do get that typical
domination of the night after widgets
it's an automatic when you just push the
pawns home okay guys thanks for watching